[Music]
wow
yeah we did it
200 200 podcast episodes
wild
wild
i feel like we should celebrate somehow
definitely
do something you know what are you
thinking i don't know i just feel like
we should pay homage to
you know i don't know where we came from
what the podcast used to be
you know for the people who have been
listening to us since the early days
yeah all the people have been quoting
squad 680 for the last three years
that's a good
idea we could actually we could squat
some weight
all right yeah yeah
candice i'm gonna get changed but while
i do that
can you bring in those weights
come on brother you got it i'm gonna
take you all through this lift right now
that noelle's about to do we got two
four six eighty on the bar and he's
doing one to two max
max reps
let's do it buddy let's go let's go you
got this come on come on
you got this let's go
let's go let's go up up up up come on
put it up put it up get that boat up
come on get it up get it up let's go
let's go brother oh my god
all right light work light work you did
it you put it up that's what i like to
see 680 put it down
oh my turn while i'm at the dead lift it
from the ground
dead lift all right
all right brother take us through it get
hyped
[Applause]
here he goes he's going in
680
from the back
use that ass
get ready brother get ready
and
[Laughter]
you put it down
i'm gonna vomit looking at this [ __ ]
dude
we gotta get this out of here oh my god
look at that is this
nice you're back in your
yeah back in the old clothes yeah oh
nice yeah cool
cool good to see it
you don't you don't lift in your leisure
okay yeah that's true lifting and
leisure do not cross no i i
i purposely buy
like under armour [ __ ] that's kind of
hybrid yeah so that i can wear it
because you never know when you might
lift that's true like i'll just lift
like as i'm walking down the street and
i see some [ __ ] on the sidewalk just go
for it yeah yeah like do ten
you know walking through a costco see a
loose parking block yep get on your back
yeah start pressing oh yeah
easy yeah what are you training for dude
life
you just never know man what are you
training for
never heard of
life
ever heard of every damn day
i have
from that jake paul song
every you know what's it called every
damn every dang day every darn day
i believe it's called
it's every darn day brother oh he made
that song dang it's every day dang it's
every day joseph
right
yeah isn't that what it's called by the
way everyone uh on this 200th episode we
we definitely not definitely but we want
to say a huge thank you
uh to everyone who tuned into the live
stream
if you didn't
uh we got another one coming up so
you know you uh definitely you me you
missed the hell of a show you missed a
hell of a night that was so ridiculous
unhinged yeah
it got okay wild pure chaos i mean it
got wilder than we ever thought it could
it was i don't know i
i'm not even trying to hype it up like i
don't know if you felt this way but i
came out of that feeling a totally
different i don't know it was just
out of all the shows you've ever done
i've never felt anything like that
can i just describe what happened yeah
like this isn't like ruining anything
like you know if you miss it you missed
it you won't get the yeah the i don't
know the magic of the moment but this is
what [ __ ] happens so we we had
planned to do a live that's cringe uh to
this video that's on vice it's like a
vice documentary that they did about
this guy who is a freelance sperm donor
yeah and his name is kyle gordy
and so we did it we reacted to that
video for about an hour right and it's
it's kind of a wild ride because at the
start you're like this guy is weird and
then you're like
this is weird this is weird this whole
concept is weird
freelance sperm donor in the sense where
he gives away his sperm
to women yeah for free doesn't charge
them and it's like lesbian couples and
so at the beginning you're like oh maybe
this guy's doing a good deed and then it
gets kind of weird and so we're watching
this video for an hour and we're kind of
like this guy's kind of a villain yeah
like he's a bizarre dude yeah and then
we uh played the cody noel do and as
that was playing
we like basically someone that had
watched the live stream live stream was
like snitched on us and dm'd him and was
like hey cody and noel are watching your
video right now and he dm'd us back and
we ended up getting him on a zoom call
for the last like half an hour yeah of
the show and i mean it could not have
been more
unhinged i keep using that word but
that's like the perfect word to describe
it it was just
[ __ ] bizarre and the everyone
was
you know
i could feel the tension
behind the the console
i could feel everyone's tension
the whole ship
i could feel the panic
yeah of
when can we cut this off it was like a
car crash oh yeah like all the tweets
were like oh my god this is incredible
but like i want it to stop so bad yeah
yeah chat was going crazy i can't look
away yeah how do i look away yeah chat
was just like
what like no like no more he basically
answered the zoom call and he was like
hey sorry my mom's screaming at me right
now uh you know like
she's making me like she's moving out
soon though so i can finally jerk off in
peace it's hard to jerk off when she's
listening to television upstairs way too
loud it was the first 10 seconds yeah
that was the first 10 seconds of the
call we're like what
what yeah so you're for real then yeah
we didn't really know what we got into
but you know um
uh
he
he definitely spoke to us that much we
can say yeah
and
but outside of that you know it just
the show itself was like just
it was a lot of fun yeah it was a ton of
fun carrington from love island was on
he was uh he was our bartender he was
bringing us drinks
that was cool yeah
shout out to him thanks for coming out
i had a i had a hand i had a good
handful
yeah you know a decent amount yeah i was
definitely buzzed oh yeah i went out
afterwards to celebrate and just
yeah
i just it wouldn't the next day was not
fun yeah
a message we had meetings and i almost
messaged the thread and was like i can't
do these [ __ ] meetings yeah but i was
like no what do you what are you doing
you you messaged me and i
i forgot what i said and you just
replied i'm hung the [ __ ] over
yeah it was not a not a fun day
but it was a it was a fun show and and
so yeah we just want to say thank you
and
uh you know we're gonna do another one i
think end of september is the plan or
something like that but yeah we'll see
we're planning it right now we're gonna
lean into this unhinged chaotic nature
that seemed to work so well because it
was
it was just fun you know i was nervous
at first i was like literally when we
started because you know there's a lot
more people here that beamed up to help
with the
production and everything and so it's
like felt like a real live show i was
like [ __ ] yeah we got to make jokes this
isn't like a standard thing yeah we're
just sitting here yeah
it was i was nervous and then like we
started drinking a little bit and
started to get like well
you know dare i say unhinged
it was getting loosey it was getting
loosey and we started just becoming you
know
filthy boyos a couple of filthy boyos
man
filthy little deviants